they call it the March of death for
Elias pilaf it's probably the most
difficult journey of his life yet still
he makes it every single year it was on
this path through the forest that he
fled for his life running from Bosnian
Serb soldiers they were on a manhunt and
he was their prey every step during they
were during this very full very hard
memories I'm thinking
my friends many my friends and relatives
didn't survive more than a thousand
people are walking with him their
destination 20 years after the massacre
that took place there is Trevor nitze
they're going back to where the refugees
fled from it's a hundred kilometers in
three days the scars of the war are
still visible today minefields lie on
each side of the pathway reminders of a
terrible time it was hell minefields
fire ball base call our almonds on every
step killing 1995 the Bosnian Serb army
closed in on the protection zone that
had been declared by the United Nations
near the Serbian border thousands of
Bosnian civilians sought protection in
the headquarters of Dutch UN soldiers
but the blue helmeted force was weak in
number and only likely armed crucially
they have no mandate to resist fear
drove the people to flee thousands
formed a column a kilometer long
desperately trying to reach safety
at the time Elias pilaf was a surgeon at
serenitas hospital it was clear to him
that the UN soldiers would not be able
to defend the city he had to make a
decision and opted to flee he left just
an hour before the Bosnian Serb army
took the city hi the soldier separated
women and girls from the men and boys
they herded them onto buses it was a
final parting more than 8,000 Muslim men
and boys were killed including Elias p
labs brother for this year's I have a
big question inside of my heart I asking
myself did I did did I do enough for him
maybe I can do more I don't know
almost everyone on the memorial March
has a story like his many families are
still waiting for the remains of their
relatives for them even 20 years on
Robben Itza remains an open wound